siamo a rivers e benvenuti in un
nuovissimo
video chi mi segue su instagram sa
benissimo che io ho due passioni i video
sulle unghie stranissime e video sulle
torte stranissime oggi approfondiamo il
tema torte stranissime fatemi sapere nei
commenti qualità queste torte li hanno
sconvolto di più ma bando alle ciance
partiamo subito perché dobbiamo lasciare
la parola a loro partiamo con una presa
una presa torta cioè io vi chiedo ma da
dove le vengono gli vengano so se un
uomo la donna chi realizza queste torte
c'è una torta una presa che si taglia la
parete la presa e dentro c'è la torta ci
sono scioccata
cioè non è non è bellissima questa è una
scatola di burro c'è una bellissima
scatola di burro ma in realtà è una
torta
cioè io veramente sono basita come fanno
a cioè la condizione come fanno
ricrearla così perfetta
c'è sembra effettivamente plastica ci
sono già la parola di questo video sarà
scioccato e preparatevi passiamo a una
torta un po schifosa diciamoci la verità
perché ok che finzione però la spazzola
con i capelli incastrati in mezzo
proprio non mi verrebbe voglia di
mangiarla non so a voi ma allora questo
mi ha colpito particolarmente perché ho
degli stivaletti identici invece posso
uguali vi farò vedere mi rifarò vedere
ecco anche qui ragazzi come si fa a
creare a ricreare uno stivaletto che
sembra proprio di cuoio cioè
perfetto con una torta ecco cos'è e
cioccolato che è quello al cioccolato
però al cioccolato come fai a farlo
diventare così somigliante a uno
stivaletto questo bellissimo mazzo di
asparagi che io amo tra l'altro qualche
giorno fa ha fatto un buonissimo
risottino appunto quelle asparagi ecco
però questi non sono asparagi in questo
blocco di asparagi in realtà è una torta
e anche qui mi chiedo di quale materiale
sono fatti questi asparagi per essere
cosi cosi pianti agli asparagi veri
questa è una di quelle che mi ha
scioccato di più forse perché sono un
amante del tè e uso il bollitore 40
volte al giorno
ok stop il bollitore è una torta e fin
qui forse non vi siete stupiti vedi
tanto perché più o meno siamo in linea
con quelle che abbiamo visto fino ad ora
ma la cosa scioccante è quella che sta
arrivando adesso perché anche il filo è
finto cioè è fatto di non so quale cibo
materiale non so più cosa dire anche qui
colpo di scena perché vediamo questa
fantastica rancia diciamo che va beh una
torta a forma di arancia cioè dopo che
potrebbe ha visto che cosa sarà mai
ma non solo
l'arancia è una torta
anche la parete davanti è fatta di torta
ed è una cosa che io assolutamente
quando visto proprio non mi aspettavo
passiamo agli elettrodomestici perché
abbiamo un fantastico ferro da stiro
fatto di torta e
molto divertente pensare a chi potrebbe
mai chiedere una torta di compleanno a
forma di ferro da stiro
forse mia mamma la chiederebbero che ha
una passione per stirare a proposito
elettrodomestici perché per merenda
insieme alte non mangiarsi una bella
fetta di microonde
ci sta ci sta ci sta
forse un po pesantina nel senso c'è
dunque un microonde però potrebbe essere
interessante
ragazzi come fa a essere così perfetto
c'è anche vedete quando quando taglia il
così dice il vetro del del microonde
come fa a essere così riflettente qui
passiamo all'abbigliamento con un
fantastico berrettino di lana che anche
qui è realizzato perfettamente ma anche
la neve sulla quale appoggiato è una
torta quindi è un blocco artistico molto
invernale di torte e berrettino di lana
finiamo in bellezza e soprattutto visto
che
è quasi ora di pranzo salendo fame
questa fantastica
box di chicken di alette di pollo di
scegliersi in realtà è una torta e io
rimango senza parole perché cioè di cosa
sono fatti questa di tipo le scritto la
fonte se c'è tutto tutto per me è un
enigma cioè io voglio conoscere questa
artista che realizza queste torte
chiedere prima teriali che usa e sotto
dove le so dove si reinventa cioè le
sogna la notte domanda umani ma li
faccio un micron
allora ragazzi
l'ultimo questo è l'ultimo perché stavo
scorrendo e ho visto questo tolone che
volava nella cuccia di questa ragazza
finalmente vediamo il volto di questa
ragazza cioè ha fatto una torta forma di
drone io qui alzo le mani fatemi sapere
nei commenti quali di queste torte vi
hanno scioccato di più e subito fatemi
sapere sky c'è di cosa sono fatti cioè
il pasta di mandorla past che non
capisco cioè non è il mio mondo quindi
se c'è qualcuno che lavora nel mondo
della pasticceria mi dia delucidazioni
perché ne ho bisogno io vi mando un
bacione noi ci vediamo al prossimo
video